[Música]
sentarme mi nombre es felipe garage de
sepúlveda soy emprendedor estudio en la
universidad desarrollo voy en cuarto año
bueno tercero y medios segundo bueno
tengo 21 años importante no tengo idea
en qué año voy lynn
les quiero comentar que hace un tiempo
me di cuenta que muchas personas tienen
teléfono hoy en día cuántos de nosotros
tenemos un teléfono inteligente en
nuestros bolsillos yo le aseguro que
todos hoy en día existen más de 30
millones de teléfonos vigentes en
nuestro país 30 millones que hacen que
en teoría estemos más conectados que
antes la pregunta es lo estamos
realmente
la respuesta es
no perfecto supuestamente con esos 30
millones de teléfonos tenemos que estar
más conectados
existen dispositivos como estos
que supuestamente nos ayudan a estar más
atraído con nuestros pares muchos de
nosotros los tenemos nuestros bolsillos
los traemos nuestra gente llevamos
nuestros compromisos e incluso llevamos
nuestras relaciones con nuestros seres
queridos
aparatos que paradójicamente alejan los
que están más cerca pero acerca de los
que están más lejos esto no es una
crítica a los teléfonos móviles por el
contrario
por otra parte
todos nosotros tenemos un imán como este
que nos permite atraer personas bienes
que nos pueden hacer tanto bien como mal
y es de fácil acceso e interno a
nosotros el teléfono es externo el limón
es interno
se nos entrega lo compramos lo vendemos
se tranza en la plaza
tiene vida útil por otra parte el imán
que nosotros tenemos ahí es interno a
nosotros está dentro de todos a uno de
los presentes no sólo de algunos sino
dentro de todos
estiman en nuestro lenguaje universal
nos permite comunicarnos y conseguir
todo lo que nosotros queramos lo bueno
es gratis si no se compran y se venden
y no tiene vida útil
hace dos años comencé con mi historia
como emprendedor corbatas diseños
innovadores buen precio
algo mejor
bueno resulta que hayan hartas cosas
mejores
de momento que inicie cuenta que no eran
solamente corbatas como la que yo no
ando trayendo
era un concepto
como verdad corbatines
lo voy a trabajar en un concepto era lo
que siente una persona al usar una
mister time logramos eso hablaba por la
opinión de todos nuestros clientes no lo
íbamos a quedar tranquilo hasta que las
personas no se identificaran
ya no era solamente una tela dobla hacia
adentro con un par de agujeros y
costuras era el concepto la diferencia
era que queríamos llegar más allá fue en
ese momento que nos dimos cuenta del
poder que tienen los emprendedores todos
nosotros estamos aquí porque nos mueve
algo
[Aplausos]
nuestro objetivo era claro queríamos
hacer una marca diferente pero no a
diferente para nosotros era diferente
para todos los emprendedores para todos
los emprendedores no para nosotros
cuántos de nosotros estamos haciendo un
impacto en nuestro entorno
nuestra mente este consolidó
nos llenamos internamente de una
sensación de éxito que nosotros mismos
generamos una sensación de éxito que
nosotros mismos generamos
resulta que el primer paso para ser
exitoso es irse exitoso el primer paso
para ser exitoso es sentirse éxitos
transmitimos esto a varios emprendedores
y creamos de conexión likes eventos de
no más de tres horas que buscan dar la
posibilidad a emprendedores de
conectarse con otros y además nuevas
redes de negocios
es algo grande no tanto de
emprendimientos marcas de nivel mundial
100 personas con un impacto tremendo en
el desarrollo como emprendedores
la idea algo más que corbatas bonitas
pero movía la velocidad con más fuerza
con más fuerza e impacto
cuántas veces hemos sentido que
colaboramos con el resto
llamamos a emprendedores para invitarlo
a nuestro primer evento llamamos prensa
les dimos este mindshare que estaba
mente que yo le estoy hablando logramos
darle coherencia a la relación entre una
pelota de rugby y una corbata entre una
tabla para hacer equilibrio y una
corbata entre todo el ecosistema de
emprendimiento y una corbata
el segundo paso que dimos emitir y
compartir este mindset de éxito de
colaboración con todos con todo el mundo
nunca miramos en medio esta idea nunca
pensamos si va a funcionar o no lo
estábamos seguro estaba más que claro
que ha funcionado ahí funcionó
aparecimos en la prensa me llamaron para
hacer entrevistas y lo más entretenido
que resulta que las marcas ahora nos
llamaban a nosotros para estar en el
próximo evento
este increíble increíble
personalmente sentí que estábamos
conectando a personas que estamos
conectando a emprendedores imagínense
hasta un pololeo salió uno de su evento
yo estaba re contento porque al hijo
liam a poner felipe hoy mister talles
eso son las instancias que creamos para
conectar personas para conectar
emprendedores
curiosamente nuestro objetivo como marca
el año 2017 dejó de ser traer las
corbatas más bonitas del mercado pues ya
lo hacíamos
sino que se convirtió en cambiar las
instancias cambiar los reuniones
sociales y las famosas activaciones de
marca y mejorarlas mejorarlas perdón por
algo con contenido eso lo que nosotros
queremos hacer
queremos cambiar el mundo a través de
micro proyectos y de micro instancias
queremos conectar personas conectar
voces experiencias y distintas
realidades mucha gente pequeña en
lugares pequeños haciendo cosas pequeñas
pueden cambiar el mundo
cambia tu forma de pensar y cambia tu
vida
estamos cambiando nosotros estamos
haciendo un cambio nuestra villas en
nuestra vida para potenciar al resto
después de todo esto la marca se
posicionó lo más entretenido que no
contratamos la agencia no contratamos
ninguna agencia ni nadie que nos ayudara
sino que simplemente cuando tenía un
problema se presentaba yo lo resolvía
con mis propios recursos sabía que la
principal fuente resolución era yo y se
cortó
logramos hacer que la marca sonará en
todos los rincones de la universidad
mister time era un hombre conocido
afuera también yo no era una persona
popular ni mucho
así que sí que las cosas funcionaban era
porque lo hacíamos bien pero siempre
trata de sacarnos por algo
el secreto está en mí en ustedes dos no
en internet no en internet en nosotros
hace un tiempo un amigo me dijo oye tú
marketing es mejor que tu cortada junto
pero con respeto
mire cómo está diciendo bueno pues
resultaba que yo no era popular y yo
estaba convencido de que sí que las
cosas no funcionaban les repito era
porque lo hacíamos bien porque no
supimos conectar con los emprendedores
correctos y lo dimos a conocer la
invitación es que ustedes se conecten
con las personas que les ayuden a crecer
con quienes le ayuden a llegar más lejos
de lo que ustedes
para eso estamos acá
resulta activo desde ese momento le cabe
a tomar más fuerza y mucha gente me
decía lo mismo literal comillas tu
marketing es mejor que tu corbata yo que
hablo porque mucha gente me lo dijo
y listo
miran se resulta curioso porque yo pasé
mal el año pasado la universidad con un
cuatri tono más de una marca con un 49
bueno lo importante es me lancé hicimos
una agencia de branding para los
emprendedores llamada agencia 12 somos
cercanos y comprometidos con nuestros
amigos con nuestros emprendedores otro
equipos joven
es comprometido es cercano le brindamos
soluciones a clientes para poder
llevarlos por un camino correcto eso es
lo que necesitamos los emprendedores en
mi momento yo lo necesite y no lo
encontré porque nadie me dio una
solución
ahora los tres y lo comparto con el
resto cuántos de nosotros estamos
compartiendo lo que sabemos
el año pasado en febrero recibí una
invitación
para asistir a la macrorrueda de la
alianza del pacífico en bogotá colombia
yo quedé sorprendido por invitaron como
comprar internacional
a una feria en la cual fui los
empresarios más jóvenes en la cual se
venden cerca de 250 millones en dos días
250 millones de dólares en dos días
y yo compré un magneto para el régimen
me sentí como un pez gordo hacer las
cosas bien trae consigo experiencias que
nos enriquecen tanto como persona como
profesionales
estamos haciendo las cosas bien
he tenido momentos malos mía no todo ha
sido tanta felicidad y tercero medio
con el dolor de mi alma ha fallado pero
confío en el proceso es lo que
diferencia a las personas que cumplen su
objetivos y las que no
seguir confiar en el proceso no nos
rendimos tan fácil
x
perdón si nosotros no creemos nuestras
capacidades alguien más lo hará por
nosotros
estamos confiando en nosotros mismos
cuando era chico soñaba con visitar eeuu
tenía ese sueño ir a eeuu y ver a los
famosos y encontrarme con todos los de
nickelodeon ahí eso no nos va a pasar
resulta que comenzó a crecer y empezar a
jugar básquet
alguien que me llamaron se me dio la
oportunidad de jugar en un high school
en eeuu
todos unidos basket hamburguesa que
mejor está fascinado
comencé con todos los papeleos en el
colegio aprobado listo visa
me presenté ladito bonito
denegada
me fui vi como un sueño en el momento de
visitar eeuu se iba como sea los buses
pero no me admitan fácil yo quería
alcanzar mi sueño a como diera lugar
quería hacerlo semanas después de volver
de bogotá me llegó una invitación para
alumnos de mi universidad para viajar a
un programa internacional de innovación
en el extranjero
en ningún momento lo dude desde el
primer momento lo sentía mío lo sentía
mío eso es muy importante entre más de
100 personas fui uno de los cuatro
becados
viajamos no solamente eeuu sino que a
silicon valley
que una bahía cerca de san francisco en
california en la cual parte de las
mejores empresas emergentes de nivel
mundial toma el lugar google facebook
apple entre otras
también en esa zona se encuentra la
universidad tan porque quiere una de mis
metas
representamos a la universidad y también
a nuestro país estuvimos los primeros
tuvieron asistir a ese programa de
vencidas están por capacitar a más de
1200 alumnos de 200 universidades
objetivo del programa es empoderar
agentes de cambio dentro de sus
comunidades para realizar una mejora la
experiencia educativa a sus pares a
través de la innovación
después de una ardua capacitación de
seis semanas terminé yendo ahora la
mejores universidades del mundo con
programa internacional de innovación
ahora soy parte de una red tremenda de
jóvenes que hacen cambio en sus
comunidades
en posibilidades se convierten en
posibilidades
cuántas de sus imposibilidades se
convierten en posibilidades
no hay nada más potente que la fuerza
intrínseca que tenemos todos nosotros
todos para traer lo que nosotros mismos
emitimos todo se devuelve
todo se devuelve empiecen buscando lo
que les gusta hacer es el principal
motor
está en mí esta es no en google no en
internet están ustedes todos tenemos
sueños acaso no es lindo soñar
bueno les comento que más lindo vivirlo
yo y un sueño
lo ves en tu mente y lo ves en realidad
creer es crear
creer es crear el éxito de un estado
mental es una actitud una costumbre una
forma de vida
cuando comienza a trabajar para cumplir
tus metas nunca se te pasará por la
mente pero nunca sentirte exitoso en
todo ámbito antes de cumplir tus metas
acá yo les quiero demostrar que sí
eres exitoso sólo por el hecho de
sentirse exitoso
el éxito no es consecuencia de las cosas
buenas que nos pasan
las cosas buenas que nos pasan son
consecuencias nuestro estado mental de
éxito yo lo viví estoy aquí para
compartirlo con ustedes cuando di el
paso y me sentí exitoso
me sucedieron todas estas cosas no es
que yo me sienta exitoso porque me pasan
otras cosas yo le aseguro a ustedes si
es que tiene una meta la cumplirán
una persona especial me dijo
si es que nosotros tenemos solamente una
vida
porque no podemos alcanzar lo que
nosotros queremos
el éxito su éxito
está tan cerca como dar un paso
a la vuelta de la esquina
lo dan muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]